in the last couple of videos we were
trying to figure out whether there was a
meaningful difference between the
proportion of men likely to vote for
candidate and the proportion of women
and the last video we actually estimated
that using a 95% confidence interval a
95% confidence interval for the
difference in the proportion of men and
the difference in the proportion of
women what I want to do in this video is
just to ask the question more directly
or just do a straight up hypothesis test
to see is there a difference so we're
going to make our null hypothesis we're
going to make our null hypothesis let me
just get a clear screen here let's make
our null hypothesis no difference no
difference between how the men and the
women will vote or another way of
viewing it is the proportion form of men
who will vote for the candidate is going
to be the same as the proportion of
women who are going to vote for the
candidate or another way you could say
that is that the difference P 1 minus P
2 the true proportion of men voting for
the candidate minus the true population
proportion of women voting for the
candidate is going to be 0
that's our null hypothesis our
alternative hypothesis is that there is
a difference our alternative hypothesis
is that there is a difference there is a
difference there is a difference there
is a difference or that P 1 does not
equal P 2 or that P 1 minus P 2 the
proportion of men voting minus the
proportion of women voting the true
population proportions do not equal 0
and we're going to test this we're going
to do the hypothesis test with a
significance level with a significant
with a significance level of 5% and all
that means and we've done this multiple
times is we are going to assume the null
hypothesis we are going to assume we are
going to assume the null hypothesis and
then assuming the null hypothesis is
true we're going to see figure out the
probability we're going to we're going
to then figure out the probability the
probability of get
our actual sample meet our actual
difference of our sample proportions so
we're going to figure out the
probability of actually getting our
actual difference between our male
sample proportion and our female sample
proportion given given the assumption
that our null hypothesis is correct and
if this probability if this probability
is less than 5% if this probability is
less than our significance level so if
the odds of getting this these two
samples and the difference between those
two samples is less than 5% then we are
going to reject the null hypothesis we
are going to reject the null hypothesis
we are going to reject it so how are we
going to do this so if we assume if we
assume the null hypothesis what does
what does the sampling distribution of
this statistic start to look like well
the mean if we assume that p1 and if the
true population proportions are actually
the same between men and women if p1 and
p2 are actually the same then this right
here is going to be 0 this right here is
going to be 0 so what we can do is is we
can figure out we can figure out that we
got when we took the proportion of men
and we subtracted from that the
proportion of women so these are the
this is our sample proportion of men who
are going to vote for who at least in
our in our poll so they would vote for
the candidate this is the proportion of
women who said they would vote for the
candidate the difference between the two
was point zero five one so what we can
do is figure out what's the probability
assuming assuming that the true
proportions assuming that the true
proportions are equal that the mean of
the sampling distribution of this
statistic is actually zero what's the
probability that we get a disc we get a
difference of 0.05 one so what's what's
what's the likelihood that we get
something that extreme and what we're
going to do here is just figure out a
z-score for this essentially figure out
how many standard deviations away from
the mean
this is that would be our z-score and
then figure out is the likelihood of
getting a standard deviation or that
extreme of a result or that many
standard deviations away from the mean
is that likelihood more or less than 5%
if it is less than 5% we're going to
reject the null hypothesis so let's
first of all figure out our z-score so
we're assuming we're assuming the null
hypothesis p1 is equal to p2 our z-score
the number of standard deviations that
our actual result is away from the mean
the actual difference that we sampled in
the last few videos between the men and
the women was 0.05 1 and from that we're
going to subtract the assumed mean
remember we're assuming we're assuming
that these two things are equal so the
mean of this sampling distribution right
here the mean of this sampling
distribution is 0 so we're just going to
subtract we're just going to subtract 0
and then we have to divide this divide
it by the standard deviation we want to
divide it by the standard deviation of
the sampling distribution the sampling
distribution of the sampling
distribution of this statistic right
here so the sampling distribution of
this statistic p1 minus p2 now what's
the sampling distribute what's the
standard deviation of the distribution
going to be in the last video we figured
it out that we could represent it by
this formula over here but with our null
hypothesis we're assuming that p1 and p2
are the same value so let me rewrite it
we're assuming that both we're assuming
we're assuming that we're assuming that
so we're not in our last video and I
don't want to confuse the issue because
in the last video I made this
approximation over here so let me write
the clean version down here we know that
the standard deviation we know that this
guy right over here the standard
deviation of our sampling distribution
of this statistic of the sample mean of
p1 minus the sample proportion or sample
mean of p2 is equal to is equal to the
square root
is equal to the square root of p 1 times
1 minus P 1 over 1,000 plus P 2 times 1
minus P 2 over a thousand we've seen
this several videos but in the null
hypothesis we are assuming we are going
to assume that P 1 is equal to P 2
that's that's what we do we assume the
null hypothesis and see the probability
of this occurring so if P 1 is equal to
P 2 we can just represent them as just
some true population proportion so we
could say that this is going to be equal
to so we could write it like this the
square root of we can literally just
factor out a 1 of a 1 over a thousand 1
over a thousand times P times 1 minus P
plus P times 1 minus P because they're
going to be the same value that's what
we're assuming in the null hypothesis
and so this is just two of these over
here so this is going to be equal to 2 P
times 1 minus P all of that over 1,000
and we're going to take we're going to
take the square root of that now this is
the standard deviation once again of of
this of the distribution of this
statistic right over here the the sample
mean of the sample proportion for the
men minus the sample proportion of the
women now we still don't know this we
still don't know the true proportion we
still don't know we still don't know
what this true proportion is we still
don't know what that is but we can
estimate it we can estimate it using our
samples and since we're assuming that
the men and the women that there's no
difference between them we can actually
view view it as a sample size of 2,000
to figure out that true proportion so we
can actually substitute it we can
actually substitute this with a sample
proportion and we can pretend like our
survey of the men and women is just one
huge survey so you have your sample
proportion is going to be equal to we're
surveying a total of 2,000 people a
thousand men and a thousand women but
we're assuming that they're no different
that's what our null hypothesis is all
about assuming there's no difference
between men and women and we got let's
go back to our original we got six
hundred and forty two yeses amongst the
men and 591 amongst the women so we got
a total of you already forgot that 642
591 so it is 642 + 591 + 591 if you
viewed it as just one huge sample of two
thousand people we got get the
calculator out we got we got 642 642 +
591 is equal to 12 33 divided by 2,000
gives us 0.25 0.6 one six five zero zero
point six one six five and this is our
best estimate of this this consistent
simp this consistent population
proportion that is true of both men and
women because we are assuming that they
are no different so we can substitute
this value in for P to estimate the
standard deviation of the sampling
distribution of this statistic right
over here assuming that assuming that
the proportion of men and women are the
same that will or the proportion that
will vote for the candidate so let's do
that
I'll just it's going to be the square
root square root of two times P which is
point two six one six five point six one
six five x times 1 minus P one minus
point six one six five one minus point
six one six five divided by a thousand
divided by 1000 let me make sure I get
two times point six one six five that's
that P right there times one minus P
divided by a thousand we're taking the
square root of the whole thing so taking
the square root of the whole thing and
so we get we get a standard deviation of
point zero two one seven point zero two
one
so let me write this over here so this
thing right over here this right over
here is 0.0217 so if we want to figure
out our z-score if we want to figure out
how many standard deviations the actual
sample that we got of the actual sample
that we got of this statistic right over
here if we want to figure out how many
standard deviations that is away from
our assumed mean that the assumed mean
is that there's no difference then we
just divide 0.05 one by this standard
deviation right over here so let's do
that so we have point zero five one
divided by this standard deviation that
was our answer up here so I'll just do
divided by our answer and we are 2.3
I'll say two point three five standard
deviations away so our z-score our
z-score is equal to two point three five
so just to review what we're doing we're
we're assuming the null hypothesis
there's no difference if we assume
there's no difference if we assume that
there's no difference then the sampling
distribution of this statistic right
here is going to have a mean of zero
it's going to have a mean of zero and
the result that we actually got for this
statistic the result that we actually
got for this statistic has a z-score of
2.34 Z is equal to two point three four
or this is or this is equivalent to
being two point three four standard
deviations two point three four standard
deviations away away from this mean of
zero so in order to reject the
hypothesis that has to be less probable
than our significance level and to see
that let's see what critical Z what
let's see what the minimum z-score we
need to reject our hypothesis so let's
think about that a second let's think
about that a second I'll go back to my Z
table we want to have we want to have a
significance level of we want to have a
significance level of 5% which means the
entire area of our rejection the entire
area in which we would
reject the null hypothesis is 5% this is
a two-tailed test an extreme event on
either far above the mean or far below
the mean will allow us to reject the
hypothesis so we care about area over
here and over here we would put two and
a half percent and over here we would
have two and a half percent two and a
half percent and we would have 95
percent in the middle so we need to find
this critical z-score critical critical
Z value and if our Z value is greater
than the positive version of this
critical of Z value then we can safely
then that's less probable then then the
odds of getting something so extreme is
less than 5% and we can say get assuming
the null hypothesis correct so then we
can reject the null hypothesis so let's
see what this critical Z value is so
essentially we want a Z value where the
entire percentage below it is going to
be 90 7.5% because then you're going to
have two and a half percent over here
and we've actually already figured that
out this whole cumulative nine has to be
ninety seven point five percent we did
that in the last video if you look for
that you get ninety set point nine seven
five right there
it's a z-score of one point nine 1.96
they even wrote it over there so this
critical Z value is 1.96 so what that
tells you is there is less than up
there's a five percent chance so this
tells us that there is a there is a five
percent chance chance of sampling
sampling AZ statistic Z statistic of a Z
statistic greater than 1.96 assuming
assuming the null hypothesis is correct
now we just figured out that we just
sample the Z statistic we just sampled a
Z statistic of two point three four
assuming the null hypothesis is correct
so the probability of this the
probability of sampling this given the
null hypothesis is correct is going to
be less than five
five percent it is more extreme it is
more extreme than this critical z-value
is going to be out here someplace
and because of that we can reject the
null hypothesis and sorry for jumping
around so much in this video I had
already written a lot so I just kind of
leverage what I already written but
since the odds of getting that assuming
the null hypothesis are less than five
percent and that was our significance
level we can reject the null hypothesis
and say that there is a difference
we don't know 100% sure that there is
but statistically we are we are we are
in favor of the idea that there is a
difference between the proportion of men
and the proportion of women who are
going to vote for the candidate